If all the salt in the sea were spread evenly
over the land, it would be 500 feet thick.
The boa constrictor is the only living animal
whose common name is exactly the same as its
scientific name.
The eruption of Krakatoa in 1883 was the loudest
sound in recorded history.
It was heard 3,000 miles away in Mauritius.
St Vitus is the patron saint of oversleeping.
Gerbils can smell adrenaline and are sometimes
installed in airport security areas to detect
terrorists.
The citizens of Kuwait celebrated the end
of the first Gulf War by firing weapons into
the air.
20 Kuwaitis died as a result of bullets falling
from the sky.
On average, most people have fewer friends
than their friends have.
This is known as the 'friendship paradox'.
There are more than three times as many PR
staff in America as there are journalists.
Under the Wildlife and Countryside Act, it
is explicitly illegal in Britain to use a
machine gun to kill a hedgehog.
A snowflake that falls on a glacier in central
Greenland can take 200,000 years to reach
the sea.
There are estimated to be approximately 41,000
different Christian denominations in the world.
New York City drifts about one inch away from
Europe every year.
In 1969, Apollo 11 returned from the Moon
in half the time it took to get from Boston
to New York by stagecoach in 1769.
Between 1960 and 1977, the secret number authorising
US presidents to launch nuclear missiles was
00000000.
The highest scoring word in Scrabble is oxyphenbutazone,
potentially earning 1,178 points.
It is a drug used to treat arthritis.
And finally, A coal-fired power station puts
100 times more radiation into the air than
a nuclear power plant producing the same amount
of energy.